Now let's look that the answers. The first
set, -4, 1, and 5 is indeed a subset of
the original set because all of the
numbers contained in the subset are in the
original set. Let's look at the second
subset, -3, -2, 0, and 5. Since -2 is not
in the original set, this cannot be a
subset of the original set. Looking at the
subset zero. Zero is, indeed, in the
original set. So that the set zero would
be a subset of the original set. Let's
look at the set. 0.5, 0.6, 1, and 2. There
are a couple of numbers there that are not
in the original set so that, that set
would not be a subset of the original. Now
let's look at the set 4,5. Again the
number four is not in the original set so
this is not a subset of the original. And
the last set, 5 and 8. Both of these
numbers are in the original set, so this
is indeed a subset of the original set.